So one of our products is called the campus expression survey.
It's a survey designed to actually measure who was afraid of speaking up about
what topics and why,
what are they afraid of?
And it turns out everyone's afraid of the students more than the faculty.
They,
they're afraid of mostly to talk about race,
about the administrators.
Everyone's afraid of the students.
They were afraid of the students.
So I don't have,
we've not seen any of them.
I've only surveyed students.
Okay.
But from what we hear,
um,
uh,
people are afraid of,
of the students,
um,
you know,
well that's in its own manner.
Like was that real year of leaders?
That's for sure.
They let those kids come into the classroom,
the actual classroom and disrupt a class on an ongoing basis.
I mean,
yes.
And I couldn't understand that exactly.
I mean,
my response to that would be first I would tell them to leave.
Second,
I would call campus security.
Third,
if something wasn't done about it,
I just wouldn't teach the class.
So I don't understand like it,
it seems to me that it's also up to individual professors to draw a line,
which is that if you're being intimidated,
dated by students,
why do you,
why do you show up and teach the class?
I don't understand that.
So again,
people are afraid to stand up if it means that people will call you a racist,
Cabot God.
I mean,
it's,
it's weird in that situation though,
it's carried to third to go to your class,
you know,
and there's a much more proximal thread there.
That's what I mean.
That's what I'm most alarmed by is the rise of intimidation.
Intimidation is now a factor in many aspects of academic life.
And that's just terrible.
That's completely incompatible,
uh,
with,
with what we do and who we are.
Well,
it's especially,
it's especially appalling given that whatever happens in the university
campuses,
you know,
like one of the questions I've faced in Canada's,
well,
why should we care about what's happening in the,
in the Ivy Towers are going to hire these people next year.
Yeah.
Well,
it's the heart.
Like what's happening in the campuses is going to happen in society in five
years.
It's already had goats.